prêt demain dossier de notre journal
maintenant la médecine en ile de france
hier après midi à paris plusieurs
milliers d'étudiants dans la rue parce
qu'un projet de loi les inquiète parce
qu'ils ne savent pas ce que sera leur
profession demain l'île de france est
une des régions des mieux médicalisé un
récent rapport le prouve
il y à 16000 médias au total en ile de
france mais attention aux chiffres la
moitié de ces médecins sont en fait
installé à paris en banlieue la réalité
est souvent très différente notamment
dans les départements de la grande
couronne
les médecins n'aiment pas la grande
banlieue en tout cas ils s'y installent
moins volontiers qu'à paris la capitale
offre un médecin pour 300 habitants
la situation est nettement moins
florissante en seine-et-marne dans
l'essonne où l'on ne compte même pas un
médecin pour 1000 habitants
mais jusqu'à maintenant les médecins ont
eu tendance un peu paradoxalement à
s'installer là où leurs confrères
étaient déjà les plus nombreux et c'est
ainsi que un peu plus la moitié des
médecins se trouvent encore concentrés à
paris ou dans ses abords immédiats alors
qu'en revanche beaucoup de grands
ensembles et les villes nouvelles
dispose de moins de médecins que
certaines villes de province
tout se passe comme s'il y avait un
certain décalage dans le temps entre le
moment où une localité se développent et
celui où les médecins viennent s'y
installer
il est certain que beaucoup d'habitants
de la banlieue tu hésites pas à se
déplacer dans paris pour consulter des
médecins et surtout les spécialistes qui
sont particulièrement nombreux à paris
car une des originalités de l'île de
france c'est qu'elle possède presque
autant de spécialistes de généralistes
alors que partout ailleurs les
généralistes prédomine
en général les étudiants cherchent à
s'installer le plus possible près de
l'endroit où ils ont fait leurs études
et il est certain que les centres
hospitalo universitaires se trouve à
paris ou dans les environs même de paris
donc il ya eu un phénomène d'éclatement
si vous voulez ou pendant un certain
temps dans la seconde couronne c'est à
dire l'essonne les yvelines le val
d'oise et la seine est mort en a manqué
deux médecins les médecins répugne trop
souvent à s'installer dans les quartiers
d'urbanisation récente c'est pourtant là
que les besoins médicaux sont les plus
importants en raison de l'évolution
démographique de la forte population
enfantine et du niveau social des
habitants
l'objectif prioritaire est donc de
réduire le décalage entre urbanisation
et médicalisation
il ya peut-être un manque de
coordination entre les services
d'urbanisation des villes nous
elles les conseils de loeb qui pourrait
diriger facilement les médecins vers ces
villes nouvelles
mais pour ce qui est de l'exemple d'evry
par exemple nous n'avons jamais été tenu
au courant des développements que
pouvait prendre des vrilles et des
besoins d'implantation médical
mauditement de coordination justement
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas envisager
des mesures un peu plus coercitives pour
régulariser l'installation des médecins
j'en suis un médecin libéral je pense
qu'il faut jouer le jeu de la médecine
libérale et qui n'est pas question
justement d'employer des mesures
coercitives pour obliger les médecins à
s'installer là et pas ailleurs
seul espoir donc de résoudre les
problèmes de démographie médicale que
les jeunes médecins soient moins
routinier que leurs aînés dans la ville